Succesul algoritmului nostru VQE depinde mult
de starea și circuit-ul
pe care alegem să le folosim la început.
Sunt Victoria Lipinska și în acest video
vom explora opțiunile
pe care le avem în proiectarea lor.
Să aruncăm o privire mai atentă
la toate elementele
pe care le avem în fiecare rulare a părții
cuantice din VQE.
Începem cu starea de referință,
numită uneori stare inițială.
Rulăm starea de referință
printr-un circuit parametrizat numit
formă variaţională,
cu o alegere inițială de parametri,
și măsurăm starea
în baza Hamiltonianului
după ce o trecem prin circuit,
pentru a obține valoarea de așteptare. Acum
vom parcurge fiecare dintre aceste elemente,
începând cu starea de referință.
O alegere tipică pentru starea de referință
este starea zero.
Aceasta este starea în care un calculator
cuantic este deja inițializat.
Pentru problemele de chimie cuantică,
se poate folosi și așa-numita
stare Hartree-Fock,
care este rezultatul metodei
Hartree-Fock.
Pe scurt, teoria Hartree-Fock
oferă o modalitate simplă de construire
a stării de referință prin aproximarea
stării fundamentale a unui sistem cuantic.
Găsește o rotație
în spațiul stărilor
care minimizează energia stării fundamentale.
În cele din urmă, starea de referință
poate fi și foarte specifică problemei,
și este posibil să vrei să alegi
o stare personalizată.
În cazul în care știi ce proprietăți
are sistemul tău, de exemplu, simetrii
sau un număr specific de electroni
în stare, poți folosi asta
pentru a obține o convergență mai bună
a algoritmului VQE.
Alegerea unei stări de referință bune
este importantă pentru convergență —
stările de referință care sunt aproape de
starea fundamentală
pot face problema să conveargă
mult mai ușor și mai rapid.
La fel de importantă
este alegerea valorilor inițiale ale parametrilor
pe care le introducem în forma variaţională.
Prin urmare, în funcție de starea de referință
și de parametrii inițiali,
putem converge rapid, lent
sau deloc.
Să ne uităm la această grafică
și, în scop de vizualizare,
să ne imaginăm că spațiul nostru de parametri
are un singur parametru.
O stare de referință foarte bună
îți poate permite să începi foarte aproape
de starea fundamentală finală
și atunci convergența va fi rapidă.
Pe de altă parte, dacă începi foarte departe
de starea fundamentală, aici,
starea de referință
a, va trebui să traversezi o barieră de energie înaltă
ce duce la o convergență foarte lentă
sau la nicio convergență.
Vom discuta asta mai în profunzime
în modulul de optimizare clasică
din acest curs.
Acum să ne uităm la circuit-ul parametrizat
care acționează asupra stării de referință, a.k.a.
forma variaţională.
Când acest circuit, U de theta, acționează asupra stării de referință,
produce ceea ce numim o stare de test
psi de theta sau uneori ansatz.
Această stare ansatz este cea care
e măsurată ulterior într-o bază adecvată
pentru a obține valoarea de așteptare
a energiei.
Formele variaţionale
despre care discutăm aici
WEBVTT
sunt motivate de chimie.
Totuși, ține minte
că există și unele inspirate
din machine learning cuantic
și din alți algoritmi pe termen scurt,
precum algoritmii de optimizare
aproximativă cuantică.
Să discutăm
câteva alegeri comune pentru un ansatz chimic.
Unitary coupled cluster sau UCC
este metoda propusă inițial
în prima publicație VQE,
și este folosită frecvent
în problemele de chimie cuantică.
De obicei,
când parametrizăm o stare cuantică,
lucrăm cu un număr exponențial
de parametri.
Totuși, pentru a face circuit-urile
de pregătire eficiente,
avem nevoie de un număr polinomial
de operații
și prin urmare de un număr polinomial
de parametri.
UCC este un exemplu de modalitate de pregătire
a unei stări de test cu un astfel de circuit
și derivă din metoda coupled cluster,
care este standardul de aur
în chimia cuantică.
Cea mai comună alegere este unitary
coupled cluster
singles and doubles
ansatz sau UCCSD pe scurt.
Deoarece UCCSD este motivat de configurația
electronică specifică a unei probleme,
trebuie să ne asigurăm că avem o stare
de referință care reflectă corect sistemul.
Aceasta este starea Hartree-Fock.
Ansatz-ul UCCSD oferă de obicei
o bună aproximare a stării fundamentale
deoarece captează excitațiile electronice
simple și duble dintr-o moleculă dată.
Numărul de parametri din UCCSD scalează
pătratic cu numărul de orbitali
de spin.
UCCSD poate fi foarte bine
adaptat la o problemă,
dar din păcate, scalarea pătratică
duce totuși la circuit-uri foarte adânci
care sunt dificile pentru calculatoarele
cuantice actuale.
De aceea cercetătorii IBM au propus
o abordare mai euristică,
în care se poate adapta o formă variaţională
la hardware-ul de bază
rezultând un circuit
executabil eficient.
Adică, stările de test sunt parametrizate
prin gate-uri cuantice
și sunt adaptate
la dispozitivul fizic disponibil.
Aceasta este o abordare foarte euristică,
prietenoasă cu hardware-ul.
Pe baza acestor exemple, să aruncăm o privire
la spectrul de posibilități
pe care le avem pentru a exprima
forma noastră variaţională.
Multe dintre acestea
sunt deja implementate în Qiskit,
așa că te încurajez să le încerci singur
pe cea mai potrivită
pentru problema pe care încerci să o rezolvi.
Dacă ne uităm la grafic, pe de o parte
avem formele variaţionale
foarte euristice.
Unde specificitatea problemei este scăzută, dar
sunt concepute să fie implementate
pe hardware-ul real.
Sunt și foarte expresive, în sensul
că se pot exprima
multe stări cuantice cu ele.
Totuși,
o problemă care poate apărea mai târziu,
în etapa de optimizare clasică,
este întâlnirea
așa-numitei platouri sterpe,
pe care o vom discuta în modulul următor.
Pe de altă parte,
avem unitary coupled cluster,
foarte specific problemei, care funcționează
excelent în chimia clasică, dar
WEBVTT
este dificil de implementat pe hardware-ul
cuantic din cauza adâncimilor mari ale circuit-ului.
În general, calculele
pot fi mai reușite dacă poți,
în primul rând, să alegi o stare de referință
și un set inițial de parametri
care creează o stare ansatz
apropiată de starea fundamentală.
Și în al doilea rând, să eviți parametrii inutili.
Aceștia fie introduc
o adâncime mai mare a circuit-ului fără niciun beneficiu
fie creează un spațiu de parametri mai mare
de explorat, ducând la platouri
în optimizarea clasică.
Ce parametri sunt necesari este o problemă
specifică fiecărei situații
ce necesită o gândire atentă.
Să vorbim despre locul unde invitatul nostru de onoare,
Hamiltonianul, se ascunde în toate acestea.
Așa cum am învățat în secțiunea anterioară,
Hamiltonianul după maparea qubit
este reprezentat ca o sumă de
șiruri ponderate de operatori Pauli.
În cele din urmă, totuși,
vrem să evaluăm valoarea de așteptare
a Hamiltonianului nostru pe starea ansatz
produsă de forma variaţională.
Din fericire, mecanica cuantică
este simplă și liniară
și asta vom folosi
pentru a obține valoarea de așteptare.
Iată cum funcționează.
Știm că Hamiltonianul este o sumă
ponderată de Pauli —
datorită liniarității,
valoarea de așteptare a sumei
este egală cu suma valorilor de așteptare
ale fiecărui șir Pauli.
Ei bine, asta e minunat pentru că, după cum știi deja,
măsurarea în baza Pauli
este la fel de simplă ca o rotație
a bazei de măsurare standard.
În loc să măsurăm valoarea de așteptare
pe acest imens Hamiltonian reprezentat
ca sumă, evaluăm mai întâi valorile de așteptare
ale termenilor individuali
și le sumăm la final
cu ponderile corespunzătoare.
De aceea în multe resurse
vei vedea doar rotații de un singur qubit
după ansatz.
Acesta este ceea ce implementează Hamiltonianul
în fiecare execuție a circuit-ului.
În videoclipul următor,
vom explora ce se întâmplă
în etapa de optimizare clasică.
Ne vedem acolo.